soldier mindset is my term for this
often unconscious motivation
that's guiding your thinking when you're
reading an article or listening to an
argument where the motivation in the
back of your mind
is trying to defend your pre-existing
beliefs or trying to defend things that
you want to believe
against any evidence that might threaten
those beliefs and so
you're going to be much more accepting
of evidence if it supports what you
already believe or want to believe and
you're going to be much more motivated
to find flaws in evidence that goes
against your beliefs
rationalizing or wishful thinking or
self-justification
those are all facets of what i call
soldier mindset
is being as rational as possible
something that everyone should aim to do
all the time well so
like any philosophy nerd i want to
immediately define all of the terms that
you just used in that sentence so we can
understand how we're using different
words
um but i'll just i'll start with the
idea of being rational
um i think a lot of people hear that
word and they think of being
like spock from star trek where you're
not allowed to have any emotion
and you're only allowed to do things
that you can justify
in dollars and cents or in time
efficiency or something like that
that's not actually um that's not how
academics use the word rational it's not
how i'm used to thinking of the word
rational
um rationality is just about uh
forming beliefs that are as accurate as
you can that's one kind of rationality
and
another kind is just making decisions
that
um that that help you achieve your goals
whatever those goals might be those
goals could be
helping people you care about or it
could be enjoying life or
uh or you know succeeding at whatever
you want but um
but the goal of being more rational is
to just uh find more effective ways to
get those goals for lower lower cost or
sacrifice
so um defined that way uh i think it's
harder to argue that being rational is
uh is not something we should strive for
um and so yes i think
uh improving your your they're called
epistemic and instrumental
rationalities is a really valuable goal
and um
and i tend to argue that uh improving
your ability to see things clearly and
have accurate beliefs
actually is a really good way to achieve
your goals to be more instrumentally
rational and that there's a there's a
real
um a real synergy between those two
kinds of rationality that i think
people should be more aware of the
problem is that most people
aren't aware of just how irrational they
are being most people presume
that the decisions that they're making
are going to take them towards their
goals right if they have goals they
don't purposefully make decisions that
don't take them toward them but it's
kind of like
the emperor has no clothes in a weird
way they don't know that the things that
they're doing
are irrational yeah i mean i think
um in the moment we all
we we never feel like yes i'm doing an
irrational thing
but i do think that many people are able
to kind of zoom out
take a step back and think you know okay
yes i do sometimes do things that
are like predictably bad for my goals
like
i do sometimes um put off
working on a project until the day
before it's due and
i know from past experience that that
tends to shoot me in the foot and i do a
worse job and
but i still do it anyway because for
various reasons you know there's always
like a short-term temptation
um that can pull you into doing
something that you know is bad for your
goals
uh or you know you might lash out
in anger at someone um even though
there's no real there's no real
expectation there that you're gonna
improve the situation by yelling at
someone but you just feel compelled to
do it anyway
um and so i think i think people can
often recognize that at least
you know in the past they have done
things that they they
now accept we're we're not the most
rational strategy for getting the things
that they want
but in the moment it's really hard to
recognize that so why do some people
see things more clearly and others don't
so
this is a big question that i spent a
lot of time thinking and writing and
talking to people about
and i'll just try to give you a very
very simplified answer so i don't spend
two hours answering this one question
um i think some people
have uh a some people
care more about seeing things clearly
and accurately and so they're more
motivated to
um you know double check their initial
intuitive guesses about what's going on
they're more inclined to say well before
i share this story on social media that
seems really true to me
maybe i'll just spend a moment fact
checking it just to see if there's any
obvious flaw i'm missing
so some people just you know are already
more motivated to do that because they
like being the kind of person who just
sees things as accurately as possible
and then
also a big part of the puzzle i think is
that some people
just for various reasons have developed
more effective emotional
skills to cope with some of the
stressful or difficult aspects of seeing
things clearly
and it can be stressful and difficult
you know it can be uncomfortable to
notice that you were
some you know some political position
you've been taking passionately to your
friends and family or
or you know saying publicly to notice
you were wrong about that can be very
uncomfortable
or just to seriously consider
you know unflattering or difficult
truths about yourself that
you know maybe i do tend to lash out at
people unfairly or
maybe i did screw up at that um you know
that that problem at work maybe is my
fault after all
that's not fun to recognize um but
i think some people have developed tools
that allow them to
kind of tackle those situations um and
and be willing to see things clearly
even even though it's not the easiest
thing in the world so
uh i think a lot of the the task of
moving towards
um what i call scout mindset the ability
to to
really want to see things as clearly as
possible even if the truth isn't what
you wish it were
um i think a lot of that progression
involves just developing these emotional
skills
that make seeing the truth easier on you
and what's the opposite of scout mindset
right so i have this metaphor that i
talk about a lot um called soldier
mindset versus scout mindset
um soldier mindset is my term for um
this
often unconscious motivation that's
guiding your thinking when you're
you know reading an article or listening
to an argument
where the motivation in the back of your
mind is trying to defend your
pre-existing beliefs
um or trying to defend things that you
want to believe against any evidence
that might
threaten those beliefs and so you're
going to be much more accepting of
evidence if it supports what you
you know already believe or want to
believe and you're going to be much more
motivated to find flaws in evidence that
that goes against your beliefs um so
this phenomenon is new it has many names
you might have heard
it under the name motivated reasoning
that's what cognitive scientists often
call it
and then there's other sort of
colloquial terms like rationalizing or
um or wishful thinking or
self-justification
those are all facets of what i call
soldier mindset and then
scout mindset is just the alternative to
that because
you know the scout's role unlike the
soldier is not to attack or defend it's
to go out
see what's really there as clearly as
possible and
and to form as accurate a map of a
situation or
um or a topic as possible including all
of all the things that you don't yet
know or that you can't be certain about
um and always always being motivated to
learn new things that could help you
revise your map and make it more
accurate
so the map is always a work in progress
um that that
is going to be subject to revision and
so scott mindset is basically
just trying to be intellectually honest
and as objective as possible
and just curious about what's actually
true
why do you think most people default to
a soldier mindset
rather than a scout mindset i know far
more soldiers than i do scouts
yeah i mean so to be clear we're all a
mix of both
we're all you know somewhat soldiers and
somewhat scouts and we
we can fluctuate between the two
mindsets um
you know i'm often in scout mindset when
i'm thinking about some
intellectual issue but if someone is
confronting me and arguing with me and
especially if they're being kind of a
jerk about it
um then it's much easier for me to slip
into soldier mindset where i really just
want to
prove myself right um or you know the
context can matter a lot to like the
topic
someone might be uh really good at being
a scout at work
like let's say they're a trader a
financial trader and
um and maybe they're they're really good
at trying to test their own assumptions
about the market
and they're quite happy to discover that
they were wrong about something because
it means they can improve their
um their trading strategy but then they
come home and they're a soldier in their
personal relationships and they're
unwilling to even consider the
possibility that other people's
perspectives might be valid or
you know completely closed to the
possibility of problems
in their relationship things like that
so we're all a mix of both
but some people are better at being more
of a scout especially
in these especially trickier you know
emotionally ideologically fraught
situations
um and so i forget your original
question
just why do people er toward it oh why
do we why
do we so often default to the soldier
yeah yeah that's right um
right so there are there are
things that soldier mindset does for us
at least in the short term
um that can be very tempting and and can
pull us into soldier mindset even if
scout mindset is better for us in the
long run
so you know one of those benefits is
just comfort
just like feeling better about our lives
or the world
um we often are motivated to reach for
reach for defenses of some narrative in
which we're a good person
and um things that happen weren't our
fault
and you know things that are wrong with
our life are
someone else's fault so i don't know
suppose you're suppose you tend to do
poorly at standardized testing um like
sats or iq tests or whatever
you might be especially motivated to
believe articles that tell you that
standardized testing doesn't actually
measure anything important
and it's you know it's like a meaning
they're meaningless tests or something
that might be an especially appealing
belief for you to try to
accept um so soldier mindset can give us
comfort it can make us feel better about
ourselves and our lives um it can also
people also sometimes use soldier
mindset to help motivate themselves
they'll try to convince themselves that
you know if i just work hard i'm
guaranteed to succeed
which you know working hard is great and
it will help your chance of success but
there's a lot of randomness and luck in
life and a lot of things you can't
control and we're often kind of
motivated to downplay that because we
are afraid it's going to demoralize us
um and yeah there's lots of other things
that people try to use soldier mindset
for to feel good or to look good to
other people
um and that's all totally understandable
i'm i'm not i'm not going to come on
here and say you shouldn't worry about
feeling good or looking good
because those are very valuable you know
parts of being a happy and
fulfilled human being um but i think
there are better ways to get those
things that don't require you to
to tell yourself falsehoods and deceive
yourself it definitely seems to reduce
complexity
when you don't consider all of the
options and the fact that you might be
wrong
conviction goes up culpability probably
goes down
and complexity gets reduced and that
creates a scenario in which you're just
more certain
and the parameters within which are the
degrees of freedom within which you
could be wrong have been reduced
right no that's that's very well put and
i think that
that simplicity can be very appealing to
people
and it can also be a way that people are
trying to
avoid uh a common failure mode which i
agree is a failure mode that we should
avoid which is
like analysis paralysis where people are
afraid well
if i if i don't just stick to one way of
looking at things or i don't just
stick to the first plan i think of then
i'm just going to get mired in
in uncertainty i'm never going to be
able to ask uh yeah or
nihilism right exactly if you allow
yourself to
you know consider other moral
perspectives or other whatever
yeah so this is this is also a very
legitimate concern because analysis
paralysis
can be a terrible thing and i've seen
people get stuck in it um but again
i think there are better ways of
avoiding analysis paralysis that don't
require you to
you know insist on false certainty so
for example a lot of the
like very successful scouts people who
are good at scout mindset who i know
are just really good at the skill of
saying well i'm going to
uh i'm going to spend a little while
considering some options then i'm just
going to go with whatever my best guess
is right now
and i'm just going to act on that you
know i'm going to make this business
plan that seems
like i've bounded the amount of time i'm
going to consider this and
i'll just go with whatever my best plan
is that i can come up with in
a day or something and i'll just i'll go
on with that until
some new evidence comes to light that
makes you know makes it worth
reconsidering like
if i if we get some feedback from our
beta testers that
is surprising and you know makes this
plan seem flawed then we'll
we'll reevaluate then or maybe i'll
reevaluate at a set time in six months
or something but until then
i'll just act on this assumption that
this plan is worth doing
and then we'll you know revise if and
when we need to and so they're able to
keep that
awareness of uncertainty um in the back
of their mind
it's bounded in a way yeah i mean it has
to be bounded right we humans have
limited time and energy and
computational power and so you even if
you wanted to
you know consider all the possibilities
every time you wouldn't have the the
time to do that
so it's just really important to be able
to
act on imperfect information and just
trust that you can you know iterate and
revise as you go
and i think that's like a much healthier
approach than
trying to be 100 confident in you know
whatever your current guess is so that
you don't have to deal with the un
uh complexity um can you tell us that
story
from the book about the guy who got
stranded at sea
in the wrath oh yeah i just i found this
such an engrossing and um and moving
story
so the guy his name is steve callahan
and he was a a sailor um just a you know
on his own not a professional um sailor
and he
set off i think this was in the 70s or
80s i can't remember
he set off on a solo voyage across the
atlantic
and he he just had a stroke of bad luck
um
i think it was a whale hit his craft
and and broke it and so it started
sinking and he managed to
um to escape in a life raft that he had
brought on
with him on the boat but so he was alive
but he's he's
stuck in the middle of the atlantic
ocean the nearest land was
1400 miles away and he had very like you
know a little bit of food and water that
he'd managed to salvage as the ship
sank but that was it so um it was a
pretty dire
um dire situation um
and so to back up for a minute the
reason that i
focus on this story is that you know as
i mentioned soldier mindset can give us
comfort and can
reassure us um in times of stress or
insecurity or fear
and these kinds of survival situations
where
you know the stakes are life or death
can be extremely stressful
and fear inducing and because of that
people in these situations are very
often
tempted to reach for soldier mindset to
to assuage their fears
they're tempted to you know insist that
i will definitely be rescued there's no
question i will be rescued or sometimes
they go the other way and they just
collapse into fatalism and say well
there's no hope there's nothing i can do
to to salvage the situation because you
know sometimes
that little bit of hope is even more
uncomfortable than having no hope at all
because it means you have to try it you
have to worry and you have to
etc so there's all of these temptations
towards soldier mindset in a survival
situation
um and that's that's unfortunate because
in a life or death situation is when you
most
need clear-eyed judgment it's when you
most need to be able to
you know weigh the odds as best you can
of well should i
you know wait here to be rescued or
should i go out to seek help which one
strategy is more likely to work
for steve callahan the kinds of
decisions he had to face were things
like
um you know i have a few flares that i
that i've salvaged
when a ship passes by you know i have to
judge is it close enough that i should
waste one of my flares in hopes of being
seen
or is that just going to be a waste of a
flare because it's too far away um
how how much water can i afford to drink
per day
um so there are all these really tough
judgment calls that make a real
difference in whether you end up
surviving or not
and your best hope of making those
decisions uh well
is to just be as as clear-eyed objective
and realistic as possible
and so what steve callahan was able to
do
was to comfort his own fear and anxiety
without deceiving himself without
telling himself falsehoods like i'm
definitely gonna be rescued so we found
other ways i call them honest coping
strategies ways of
you know comforting yourself without
lies
uh so for example one thing he did was
just to
remind himself he used this mantra he
said
all i can do is the best i can i'm doing
the best i can which was true he was
doing the best he could he just kept
reminding himself of that and
you know and that was comforting to him
um and he also
worked on his memoirs while he was in
the boat because he figured you know
even if i die maybe someday this raft
will be found and my memoirs of this
experience could be useful to someone
else and he found that comforting too
so steve callahan relied on these honest
coping strategies that
allowed him to keep going without
deceiving himself and
his story has a happy ending um he
eventually made it after three months
almost three months of drifting in this
raft slowly across the
atlantic ocean he got to the caribbean
um i think he'd lost over a third of his
body weight at that point but
uh but he you know made a full recovery
and now his
memoirs are this amazing book called
adrift
which is a story of how he survived both
logistically and emotionally
um in the atlantic for all that time so
i i love his story just as like a
gripping adventure story and also as
this kind of emotional role model that i
try to follow
and he had five pints of water left when
he was found as well he did i was so
impressed with that what's
self-restraint you know
outrageous oh i should mention he yeah i
mean he had very little water at the
beginning but he managed to rig up this
device to collect rain water
on the raft so that he could replenish
the supply of water but still it was a
very slow rate of replenishment so he
could only afford to drink
i think it was like a liter a day or or
something you know
it amounted to about one gulp of water
per hour i think [ __ ]
yeah it's um it's interesting that you
say that he found
comfort in rationality so i was reading
red rising which is a series by pierce
brown it's just a sci-fi
fiction series that i've addicted half
of the audience to
um it's so good it's outrageously good
and in it there's this line
and the protagonist is talking about the
fact he's in this emotionally
charged situation he's at war in space
and stuff
because because of space and he um
he says someone comes in
and asks him about how he's feeling or
sort of brings him back to this
um social issue that he's having while
he's in the middle of planning the
attack this new attack that he's doing
out in space
and he says that he was ripped out of
the cold comfort of rationality
and into the emotion of it all huh and i
thought that was really poignant i
highlighted it i've saved it down in my
in my favorite quotes and this is
something that i think
i've been thinking about this for a
while to do with the rationality
movement at large
so les wrong and slate star and all this
sort of stuff
i wonder how much of the comfort that
people take
in the rationality movement at large
is them trying to wrangle the infinite
complexity of the world and the inherent
fear that comes from being a finite
creature like we are
surrounded by infinite complexity i
wonder
how much of the compulsion and the
desire and the enjoyment of the
rationality movement
comes from creating a little bit of
order
trying to reduce the amount of chaos
that you're surrounded by what are your
thoughts on that well
i guess that would seem more plausible
to me if
the non-rationalists were all wrestling
with uncertainty
and feeling but like pandora's box with
that though right isn't it it's like if
you don't
know that it's there you can't know your
own ignorance if you're still ignorant
okay okay got it so you're suggesting
like the rationalists
are people who have they have opened
pandora's box they have
they have become you know aware they've
stepped out of plato's cave yeah
right to pick another ancient uh greek
metaphor
um so they've they've become aware of
all this uncertainty and so
they're they're clinging to rationality
as a way to
try to you know wrangle it they'd all
wrangle the uncertainty into an order or
something that's just something that i
considered
it's uh it's possible i mean i'm i'm
maybe one of
the worst people to try to give a nice
uh unbiased take on your psychoanalysis
of the rationalist since i'm like more
inside of the
group than outside of it um i
i mean i'd be curious for
your take on the actual like kind of
analysis or
or you know approach to wrangling
uncertainty that rationalists tend to
use
because it's you know again i'm not
unbiased here but it's not that
simplistic
it's it's pretty complicated um there's
there's always like you know one
rationalist will suggest one thing and
then another rational to be like
well but you know we have to add this
nuance here and or you know
well but there's this flaw in that
approach and so it
it doesn't feel to me like we're just
like reaching for some simplistic
explanation no no i don't think it's i i
don't think it's sort of a reductionist
or super super simplistic approach
but i do wonder whether the the deep
core motivation part of that comes from
this desire for
for us to just make the world feel a
little bit
less crazy
yeah because we can't rely especially
the people in the rationality movement
they can't rely on the old
archetypes and narratives that would
have given them that sense why
everything's in service of god
it'll be fine when judgment day arrives
um
another question i had for you given
that you are uh knee-deep in the
rationality movement
what do you think that the rationality
movements got
most wrong over the last 10 years or so
what are the blind spots that they've
overlooked
um i'm not hesitating because i have no
answer to this i'm hesitating because
i'm trying to like winnow down all my
thoughts into something
concise um i
well okay one thing that i've been kind
of converging on in the last few years
um is that
so one of the main things that defines
the rationality community
um is a an emphasis on these kind of
norms of discourse that you're supposed
to follow if you want to participate in
discussions
um and the their norms that are intended
to kind of help
uh help push us all or keep us all in
scout mindset and make it easier for us
to kind of collectively get closer to
the truth hopefully
and so these norms include things like
um you know
you shouldn't dismiss someone's argument
just because you don't like them um you
should like
take take at faith faith value or or um
assume you know that your fellow your
interlocutor is
is arguing in good faith don't just say
you know well you would say that because
you're uh
you know white male or you would say
that because you're um just trying to
defend your country or whatever
just like deal with the arguments that
people make as they make them and just
talk about the ideas
you know um and then you know it also
includes things like
uh you should be willing to talk about
the evidence that you have for your
beliefs or
you know even if you don't have
randomized controlled trials behind
everything you say you should at least
be able to talk about
well here's here's i think what my
intuition might be based on
um instead of just saying your belief
and expecting people to take it as the
truth
you should be willing to talk about the
reasons um so
i think these are great norms um of
course i do because i'm part of this
community
but there is a potential downside to
them that i think i've become
more aware of in the last few years
which is that they're somewhat gameable
um or they to put it a different way
they
they they create the potential for
exploitation by bad actors
so you know knowing that we have these
norms
someone can come in and say well you
know
here are all of my theories about uh
whatever controversial topic and they
could they could actually be
you know quite disingenuous and even
harmful
claims um but the rationality community
has committed itself to you know
evaluating all arguments as if they're
being made in good faith
and uh and to not dismiss something just
because it sounds evil or crazy or weird
and so that can lead to some ideas being
you know taken more seriously or given
more of a hearing
just because the rationality community
doesn't feel like they're allowed to
you know reject something because
someone's a date
yeah because someone's a dick and so uh
so this has come back to bite us in some
ways
um uh you know slate star codex who you
mentioned
or scott alexander who wrote the blog
slate star codex and now blogs at um
astral codex10
has you know he's really committed to
these norms
of discourse and the comment threads on
his blog and also
on some of the like forums on reddit
that he's moderated
and you know there as you would expect
in any forum
where uh people are committed to taking
ideas seriously even if they sound weird
or fringe
um that attracts some people with like
very unpopular
unsavory ideas and the fact that
you know a prominent minority of
commenters
in his community have these unsavory
ideas has definitely been used like
against him
um but anyway i was supposed to be
criticizing the rationalists and not
defending them
i think i think that's a good i think
that's a good point that the
the playing field the gracious playing
field which is given in the
the hope of intellectual
is kind of one of the flaws to take it
back a little bit of a step i've got a
suggestion
that comes from kind of like the
kindergarten kiddies playpen version of
the rationalist movement which is
um the mental models world which has
been popularized by
shane parish from fs.blog and there's
been basically an unlimited number of
books about mental models written over
the last few years
yeah and what i think you've done a good
job of with the scout mindset
is you identify that simply being able
to
glossary term define a whole bunch of
different mental models
doesn't really do very much for us at
all the fact that i know
that i can define availability bias or
the fundamental attribution error
or survivorship buyers or
occam's raiser or handling raiser or
whatever the fact that i can identify
all of these different things
doesn't really get me all that closer to
rationality it means that
post hoc i can look back and perhaps see
what i did wrong
but you you have this quote that says
our judgment
isn't limited as much by knowledge as it
is by attitude
and i think that really hits the nail on
the head that we want we need to be
attitude and action focused if we are
going to aim toward
seeing the world more accurately making
more rational decisions
being less self-deceptive it it's
something it's not something that you
can armchair philosophize
about and i think that the rationalist
movement at least the parts of it that i
have seen
sometimes attract people who enjoy
the philosophical debate but when it
comes to putting skin in the game and
actually making
changes that's perhaps a step a little
bit further beyond
it's one that's more difficult to prove
on the internet as well so there is a
caveat there it's like i don't know
quite how much these people are making
changes but there's certainly people
with it's also the selection problem
of like the people you see arguing on
the internet about rationality are like
by stipulation the ones who are less
motivated to go out and
do things do they do the properly
rational thing but that's it just that
i think naming
there was a period about sort of three
or four years ago where everyone was
adamant that
simply by knowing all of the different
mental models that they would somehow
make it closer to rationality
and they didn't all that they did was
take up mental bandwidth learning
glossary definitions yeah
and it's called insight porn sometimes
you can get addicted to
insight porn in sight yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i mean that i i mean i agree with that
as a common
pitfall or failure mode of like the
rationalists
approach and i think i felt prey to it
too that i
uh i have a bias in favor of ideas that
are like intellectually interesting
or i have a bias in favor of supporting
causes that are kind of
yeah intellectually interesting or even
to be like less flattering to myself
um you know not normie like
i don't know some signaling right what
it's signaling
you get to say look look at look at look
at what i know oh you don't know that
don't worry don't worry i'll explain it
to you sit down
right like if i if it turned out that
the result of my
you know my mental calculations was that
the most important thing to care about
was climate change
then like in a sense that would be a bit
disappointing given my
you know personality just because like
everyone cares about climate change
that's not like a very cool thing to
care about
like i want to care about something more
esoteric or obscure or
sophisticated or something um and so
i mean i'm i'm like trying to
psychoanalyze myself and other people
like me here
and i'm just guessing that this is this
is an effect that's working in the back
of my mind and i do try to correct for
it when i can
like i try to you know i try to
motivate myself to be the kind of person
who just
really tries to care about whatever
happens to be the most important thing
and i like the idea of being that kind
of person
um hopefully more than i like the idea
of being like some esoteric
some person with esoteric tastes and
interests so uh i'm trying but i agree
that that is a kind of blind spot that i
uh suspect rationalists fall prey to
more than the average person does
i would agree so dig into that attitude
and knowledge limitation what sort of
attitudes can we have that will foster
better self-awareness um yeah well
the first thing is just to actually want
to notice yourself
uh being in soldier mindset um to
you know feel good about yourself when
you notice oh i was just i was just
being defensive there oh i
you know something i often notice is oh
when i answered that person's objection
or that person's question
i didn't actually think about it i was
just like if i pay attention to the
mental motions i was going through i was
just
reaching for something i could say that
would that would
uh knock down their objection i never
actually stopped to think about whether
they could be right
um so let me interject there what what's
the thing that you do
to create a break point in that have you
got a practice that you have
in the reflex to stop the reflex uh
well part of it is just you know simply
paying attention to it and building the
habit of noticing but there are some
concrete things
as well that help um one thing
is to uh step back
and remind myself of this is
an example of kind of an honest coping
strategy like a thing
an emotional tool to make yourself more
motivated to be in scout mindset instead
of soldier mindset even when the
temptation to soldier mindset is there
um and a specific thing i often do is
just
to remind myself that oh if i
you know if i admit that i'm wrong in
this argument that might be
uncomfortable now
but the silver lining the upside is that
by doing so i'm going to be
building this track record in which i've
proven that i'm a
i'm you know arguing in good faith and
i'm not the kind of person who's just
going to stick to what she's saying just
for the sake of it you know just
to stick to her guns and so i'm kind of
investing in my future credibility
by you know if it turns out that i
actually was wrong in this argument then
you know the the silver lining to that
is that i can build a reputation as
someone who's
a credible good faith arguer and so
sometimes just
remembering that silver lining um it
doesn't necessarily make it
fun to notice that i was wrong but it
makes it like tolerable
it makes it just palatable enough that
i'm kind of willing to do it
so i think that can help like noticing
the silver linings or the upsides to
like being wrong or um or to
yeah changing your mind um and then
i also have some tools for this for the
noticing part like tools to help you
notice that you're actually in soldier
mindset
there's a whole category of things
called thought experiments
where you just for example suppose
you're
you find yourself defending a politician
on your side
who just did something that he's coming
under attack for a thought experiment
you could do
that would be useful in that situation
is to imagine that a politician from the
other party had done the
exact same thing um what would your
reaction have been would you feel like
defending him too
or would you say like oh no that's
terrible um that's you know he should be
just
taken out of office or something like
that um i just i call that an example of
or that is an example of what i call the
double standard test where you
kind of check to see am i applying a
double standard to
people on my side versus someone else am
i applying a double standard to
judging my own actions versus someone
else am i applying a double standard to
claims i want to believe or
you know then i would apply to claims i
don't want to believe so
in situations where i think it's
possible i'm in soldier mindset i will
sometimes do a thought experiment like
that just to test
what are the thought experiments do you
like um
well another one that i use a fair bit
is called the outsider test
um and the goal there is to check to see
if
your judgment about what's best to do in
a given situation would be different if
it wasn't you
in the situation so uh
an example of some people who aren't me
using the outsider test
is comes from andy grove um and gordon
moore who are
two founders of intel in the 80s
um intel's market share so they made
memory chips originally
and their market share had been really
high but then started plummeting as
japan found ways to make memory chips
much faster and cheaper than intel and
so
everyone was kind of you know tearing
their hair and like ringing their hands
and uh in his memoir andy grove tells
the story of being
in his office with gordon
just going back and forth about what to
do um
and he asked gordon what do you think
like if
if the board kicked us out and got a new
ceo
and brought him in he walked into this
office what's the first thing he would
do
and gordon said oh he would get us out
of the memory chip business
and andy was like yeah he would so
what's stopping us from just walking out
the door coming back in and doing that
ourselves
and the answer was nothing except that
they had been so
kind of stuck in the status quo that
they were used to of like well we're a
memory chip company we should always
make memory chips it was kind of their
identity
uh andy said and it felt almost like
blasphemy to consider giving that up
but a new ceo without those attachments
would have no such
uh attachment so
uh just imagining what an outsider would
do in that situation
or like what you should what you think
an outsider should do can often cause
you to realize oh this is
you know my judgment was being clouded
just by the
by my past attachments it's almost like
um
i forget who wrote this uh some some
writer had this great metaphor of like
it's like hanging a sign around your
neck that says under new management
um and and just like getting rid of that
past baggage or imagining what it would
be like can
can give you a very different take on a
situation so a double standard test
outsider test
two examples of thought experiments that
can help you you know
notice and then hopefully compensate for
bias in your judgments
that third party perspective is so
important it's like
yeah it's such a scalable queue role
for so many of the things that you do
because we're all capable of giving
friends amazing bits of advice yeah we
say the thing the friend that doesn't
know what to do in the relationship and
you you're firm but compassionate with
them and you're understanding but you're
not
a total walk over and you maybe give a
few different points of view
and then when it comes to your own
situations you just lambast yourself
about how
short you are with your your
shortcomings are awful and you're
failing at this and
you watch your own blunders from a front
row seat and then
give yourself a kick in the ass on the
way out of the door
it's such a and you're like well hang on
a second if there's anyone that you
should be your best friend to it should
be yourself
right and yet we find it so hard to
treat ourselves like someone that we are
responsible for helping to quote jordan
peterson
and that third-party perspective to
develop that metacognizance and to step
away
from the identity i think is super super
important
you looked at whether self-deceived
people are happier
what did you find out about this yeah so
this was a bit of common wisdom
that i investigated from my book
i'm sure many of your listeners have
seen the articles and books
saying things like self-deception makes
you happy or
you know a little bit of delusion is is
good for your mental health
or things like that there have been a
lot of articles and books like this in
the last
15 years or so and so i looked into the
research that these articles and books
were citing
and was kind of appalled at how
bad it was so i'll just i'll give you
one example um here's a a scale
measuring self-deception so it's like a
a measure of how self-deceived
a person is um and the way the
researchers measured this was to ask
people questions like
um do you ever get angry
on a scale from and they ask you to
answer from one
never to seven all the time um and if
you
and their rule was if anyone gives a one
or a two then they're a self-deceiver
so in that example you might think yeah
okay well i mean everyone gets angry so
anyone who says they never rarely get
angry must be lying to themselves right
well i mean maybe i i know some people
very well
who you know they've been my friends for
years and they get angry like once a
year
i think that's me i would be in that
category yeah right and so maybe it's
not that common but there's definitely
people who rarely get angry
um and so they would honestly answer
like two out of seven
and then they would be classified as
self-deceivers and then the questions
get weirder from there
so another question is uh are you
attracted to members of your same sex
ever
like do you ever find someone of your
same sex attractive and if you answer
one or two
like never or rarely then you're
classified as a self-deceiver so the
reason because
everybody's a bit gay everyone's a
little bit gay
are we sure that the are we sure that
the researchers didn't have
a was this for the gay times was this
for the gay times
this is like these are respected
researchers whose work has been cited in
like
very best-selling books um and in very
popular podcasts and i won't name names
but
this sounds like a bad high school
problem yeah and then i'll just give you
one more question
since i i can't get enough of how dumb
this study is
um another question was uh do you ever
fantasize about
raping or being raped and if you say one
or two
like i.e never rarely you are a
self-deceiver
which i i don't think that this research
tells us very much about
self-deception um although it does
perhaps tell us a little bit about the
psychology of the researchers themselves
um so yeah
and you know that's one particular
metric that was just used in some
studies and not all of them
but but most of the studies i found
investigating this question of like
self-deception you know or finding that
self-deception makes you happier
most of those studies had some
equivalent problem in the study design
or how they were measuring
self-deception
and so i ended up just feeling like well
okay maybe self-deception can make you
happier
that might be true sometimes but i don't
believe that because of the research
the research itself is so inconclusive
and i mean i have other reasons for
thinking self-deception may or may not
make you happy but
but not research what's your what's
what's your
outcome from your own ideas oh i think
you know just based on being a human in
the world and like
observing things and experiencing things
i think self-deception can make you
happier
in the short term i think it's much less
clear whether it
makes you happy in the long term and i
my guess
is that uh just cultivating the ability
to look at things realistically
and and cope with reality is probably a
better strategy for happiness in the
long term but at least in the short term
i think
yeah it's pretty clear that it can make
you happy to you know convince yourself
that you weren't at fault or that
you know your mistakes aren't uh aren't
really that bad or
you know everyone loves you like of
course yeah that can make you happy in
the short term
do you think that learning to be wrong
is a skill then that we need to acquire
in a way
uh yeah in many ways i mean it's um
it's partly an emotional skill as i was
kind of talking
about throughout this conversation it
involves emotional tools like
recognizing the positive
the upside of admitting you were wrong
um it's also
a it involves kind of a different
frame um like a frame shift in the way
you think about being wrong
so you know i kind of alluded to
one of the aspects of being a scout is
acknowledging uncertainty and never
being 100 certain of your beliefs always
having
you know your confidence level somewhere
on a scale from zero to 100
shades of gray and not black and white
and
so that's kind of a different way of
thinking about things it's a cognitive
shift or frame shift and one nice thing
about that i find
is that it can make it easier to
acknowledge
evidence against your views because
doing that doesn't mean
giving up a belief entirely it just
means a kind of incremental
downgrade in your confidence level so if
you you know start out being
85 confident that uh i don't know that a
paleo diet
is um is the healthiest diet someone can
have
and then you read a new study suggesting
that oh actually like researchers didn't
find any benefit to the paleo diet over
whatever traditional low-calorie diet or
something
reading that study doesn't have to
immediately undermine everything you
believe it just means maybe you should
downgrade your confidence from 85 to
65 or 70 or something and then as you as
you read more and experience more and
you know maybe there's a follow-up to
the study maybe your confidence level
will go back up or maybe it will go
down even more but either way each each
time
the the update that you have to make to
your map of reality
is kind of gradual and incremental and
so i think that's like an
underappreciated benefit
of recognizing uncertainty in the world
um is that it makes the adjustments you
have to you have to do
kind of emotionally easier so there's a
number of things like that that are just
like differences in the way you see the
world
that can make changing your mind easier
we see
being right or wrong as binary right we
think okay it's either it's either that
it's
my my proposal my thesis
or something else and that's it it's
interesting that you talk about
confidence intervals because
scott alexander every year makes his
predictions for the end of the year
right
i'm 75 likely there's a 75
likelihood that my bedroom will be
painted yellow and this and this and
this
redacted i i accidentally listened to
that
on the slate star codex podcast which
was the worst thing to listen to it on
because it's just
somebody reading off statistics it's a
15 minute
it's a 15 minute bar chart graph like
thing that he was reading through they
didn't try to narrate the graph that he
drew of his calibration
and then there's a dad no no he does
that
he tries to but it's anyway yeah it's
it's slightly ugly
um but yeah i like thinking about
things in terms of that you also talk
about beliefs and identities and i
suppose that this
adds sort of a psychological layer on
top of this
the fact that you can wrap the person
that you believe that you are
around being right or another group
being wrong
so tightly that this further creates
more self-deception or more murky waters
to see rationality through
right in that um noticing that you were
wrong about some
you know maybe random political or
ideological intellectual issue
can be a blow to your identity um just
because you you pride yourself on being
the
kind of person who's always right is
that what you're saying
yeah yeah i agree um yeah i think it's
very important
to kind of tie your identity not to
having the right beliefs
because then you're you're never allowed
to change the beliefs um
but instead tie your identity to
taking the right actions and by the
right actions i mean things that
actually
help you improve over time or help you
make your map of the world more accurate
over time
and so you know i would put things in
that category like
being able to say that you were wrong or
uh being able to
understand the views of people who
disagree with you um like being able to
accurately represent
the opposing perspective you know fairly
and charitably enough that people on the
other side go yes thank you that is what
we believe
um as opposed to a straw man of the
other side um
and so i think if you pride yourself on
being able to do things like that to
change your mind and understand opposing
views
then over time you're incentivizing
yourself to do the things that make you
stronger and more accurate over the over
the long term as opposed to priding
yourself on holding a particular view
that you then can't let go of
it's inevitable that you're going to
have to loosen your grip on your
identity
if you are constantly seeking out
counterpoints to
your position right you can't be a good
faith
actor intellectually in any kind of
discourse and steal man somebody else's
position properly without thinking well
this
this actually does mean that i need to
let go of the identity that i have
that's wrapped around my particular
ideology or my particular viewpoint
a little bit it has to do and i think um
thinking about it from a competitive
advantage standpoint
there are so many ideologically bound
bad actors
that are just sort of dogmatic single
track thinkers now especially in 2021
with
social media and sort of extremism out
to both sides etc
now more than ever yeah you can
stand out from the crowd by being
radically reasonable
far more reasonable far more easily than
you can by trying to be an extremist
yeah like this is the the i think it's
an underrated niche honestly
honestly an extreme centrist um is
a really radical position to hold now
surprisingly
i did this video about sam harris a few
months ago where i said that
um what you do by holding a nuanced
viewpoint that is non-typical and also
um somewhere in the middle you're paying
a high cost because you guarantee
disagreement from both sides
by being in the middle you guarantee
disagreement from both at least when
you're out on one
extreme you know that you're going to be
agreed with by that group
right right so what it is it's a hard to
fake
signal of intellectual honesty because
you need to pay
a very high price to be in that middle
and what are you signaling i am the sort
of person who has
thoroughly thought through his ideas i
am the sort of person who's prepared to
take slack
uh flak from both sides simply because
i want to be right here even though it
would be easier for me to be out towards
the edges
and um if people want to
separate themselves out from the pack i
think that's quite
again you can gamify the system and you
can purposefully choose to have a
nuanced viewpoint and always talk about
how you oh it's always above both sides
thing mate
um but overall
i think yeah sitting in the middle makes
a lot of sense
yeah i mean i i think that's that's very
well put
and i think um you know
you're never going to appeal to everyone
and so
you know you just have to decide like
what kind of audience
am i optimizing for impressing and
winning the respect of
and you know you could optimize for
winning the respect of the audience that
just like passionately believes
one thing and they just want to hear you
say that and reaffirm it
um that's like a choice you could make
um but you could also optimize for
winning the respect of the audience that
is like more discerning and
cares a little bit more about what's
actually true and is more
uh more interested in hearing challenges
to the things that they believe
um and you know
it's not a tiny fraction like it's a
minority of the overall population but i
don't think it's a small minority
um and this i think this nuance like
tends to get washed out sometimes when
people say things like oh
no one wants nuance or no one wants to
hear uncertainty no actually a lot of
people do
um not like 90 but like a lot of people
and
in my experience the subsection of the
population that
appreciates the nuance and the and the
you know
challenge to their views is kind of a
cooler subset
than most of the other subsets um i
agree i agree completely
yeah this is something that i was on my
podcast a few months ago i was talking
to
vitalik buterin as a co co founder of
ethereum
and he he's someone i reached out to
i've been following for years and um and
always admired his kind of intellectual
honesty and his commitment to
talking about things that he now thinks
he was wrong about with respect to
ethereum or
you know acknowledging the downsides of
the plan the direction that he's chosen
um and saying you know this is what i
think is best overall but i agree it has
some downsides
or you know yeah acknowledging
acknowledging his uncertainty about
different aspects of the future of the
currency and
so i asked him like has that had
downsides for you like that intellectual
honesty
and he said well you know in some ways
yes like sometimes
journalists will will take a quote out
of context to make it sound like i'm
you know not i have no faith in ethereum
or something like that
but it's a conscious strategy i've
chosen he said
because the kind of people who who like
that
intellectual honesty are the kind of
people who i think are going to make
ethereum
a stronger community the kind of people
i like and whose respect i care about
and i think they just
yeah make for a stronger community
building what i want to build
and so that's kind of how i feel too um
that i just that's the kind of people i
want to optimize for even if they're
not a majority if it's good enough for
the guy that founded ethereum i think
it's good enough for the rest of us
uh julia gayliff ladies and gentlemen
the scout mindset will be linked in the
show notes below why some people see
things clearly
and others don't if people want to check
out more of your stuff where should they
go
uh well my website's julia gayloff.com
and you can also follow me on twitter
i'm just
julia gailiff i'm the only julia gayliff
in the world so i'm not hard to find
um and you can you can join the you know
i like to talk about these ideas on
twitter and
especially kind of hash out some of the
the ideas around the edges that i'm less
confident about or
you know think i might be wrong about
and so you know come join the fun
i love it thank you julian thank you
chris this was so much fun
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe it makes
me very happy
peace
you